there's a principle at stake at this
point at first we just wanted a fun show
now we're making a point I mean I
suppose in a way though even comedy
unleash being at the fringes is making a
point in so far as we exist in a comedy
industry that hates us they hate the
fact that we exist we are constantly
bombarded with nonsense from Comedians
and the occasional hit piece from
magazines like Vice because the idea of
a free thinking comedy night the idea of
a night where we say people might be
offended but that's their issue you know
where we might have subversive Comics I
mean when we started we got lots of
comedians saying this is unnecessary
people aren't being canceled or censored
what you're doing we've been Vindicated
of course because so many comedians have
now had shows taken away from them but
in addition to that ever since we
started we've had a steady stream of
emails over the years of people saying I
can't do my material anywhere else
anymore can I come and do it at your
club now if it were the case that
self-censorship is not a problem in the
comedy industry why do I keep getting
these emails